good morning John we are about to have
gone around the Sun again that's right
my next line where this video will be
made in the year 2015 over on the side
show Michael Aranda just gave us some of
the science superlatives of 2014 deepest
diving whale ever recorded the most
earth-like planet the highest co2
emissions and the warmest months ever
recorded 2014 has been a big year in
science but it's also been a big year in
general so here on a vlogbrothers where
things are more general let's talk about
some of the biggest bestest superlative
ax stings that happen this year first
with the very likely possibility that
this will have been the warmest year
ever recorded and while we are an
adaptable species and I do have a lot of
faith in us figuring out how to grow all
the food we need to grow with water
landing in different places than it used
to land and protecting all of the
infrastructure we already have with new
infrastructure that's going to be very
expensive pissah it is also good news
2014 saw the youngest ever recipient of
the Nobel Peace Prize Malala yousafzai's
acceptance speech made me cry probably
will make you cried too if you watch it
and it also gave me hope about some very
depressing seemingly hopeless situations
so that's 17 what was I doing that Alice
17 I can't even talk about it I know it
was also possibly the best year ever
to be a nerd Sherlock came back orphan
black is awesome we're getting new Star
Wars movies and new Star Trek movies and
new Avengers movies we had a new x-men
movie dr. new Veronica Mars new cosmos
he landed a probe on a comet curiosity
realized that it's definitely for sure
roving around on an ancient Martian lake
bed a female Thor and a black Captain
America it's been a good year also
venture to say that it's the first year
in decades when America broadly decided
that it had to confront its you know
sort of mess like racism that's what it
that's Michael Brown Eric garner John
Crawford 12 year-old Tamir rice were all
killed by police officers and we're all
unarmed I ended up itself that's
actually not unusual which is sad thing
to have to say unarmed black men are
shot and killed by police officers every
year this isn't like a new explosion of
police shootings what's different is all
of the Americans mostly Americans of
color who stood up and said that they
have had enough and advanced a national
dialogue about police wearing body
cameras about the difficulties of being
a person of color in America about the
systemic racism in the justice system
these are problems that we've always had
but that we haven't
talked about for a long time like
somehow racism went away after
segregation discussions about systemic
sexism were also advanced with Emma
Watson's he for she speech the United
Nations in that video that got like 30
million views of this woman just walking
around New York being harassed one final
first for you here in Missoula Montana
we had our first same-sex marriage at
the courthouse which this I can't
believe it took so long but it happened
as within a year there's been good and
there's been bad and we talk more about
the bad than about the good but maybe
that will lead us to fighting against
the bad so that next year in 2015 there
will be less of it though I'm sure the
amount of it that we have is what we
will mostly talk about again as always
without from some people on Twitter I've
created a playlist of some of the most
important YouTube videos of 2014
including Emma Watson and malala's
speeches and cgb great talking about why
Mandy and the future jobs won't exist
should you be happy or sad I'm not sure
everyone thank you for another great
year here at vlogbrothers in John I'll
see you on Tuesday